a hit like a a bachelorette okay okay
uh so yeah we're on a bachelorette and
she said she heard her boss
a bell went off on his phone she was
like i've heard that sound before
where's that from
she'd heard it on tik tok it's from
advance turns out him and his wife have
dsm only fans they're married with kids
do you think that's an optimal
environment for kids to grow up in with
um basically anyone can pay ten dollars
and see their parents having sex because
if you come if you if you went to my
school your mum's breast is going around
all demanding facts
that's your mom's best maybe not optimal
but reality now so what do you think
what do you what effect do you think
that will have do you think it's just
going to become the norm do you think
i hope i think i hope not all my mates
bashing over my mom's breasts like no no
what if they did it anyway without a
picture
what would they
because at the end of the day it's it's
selfish because you're putting you above
your kid you're putting like wanting
quick cash because that's another way
women are bailed out right if a man
doesn't have a job he's just homeless
if a woman doesn't want to work she can
go on only fans and make six figures
yeah and so it's
it's
you can't really feel bad for those
girls either and say oh you're forced to
be sexualized because i don't feel bad
yeah no it's good good
be good but a lot of a lot of those
girls will say that and then come in
after mia khalifa
right
and then come back and and what's the
other girl the
jake paul's
friend's girlfriend
lana rhodes lana rhodes
came back and then says oh i regret it
later but it's like but you got all the
benefits and so they just want quick
cash and they're willing to put their
kids and their family's reputation
in the name of it
and yeah i don't think that's ideal for
kids
i'm not saying women can't be sexual at
all but i just think in a relationship
it's going to be better if you do it in
the context with your husband like she
could have she could have went to since
she is a dancer she could have went to a
dance class choreography and there would
have been twerking in the choreography
personally i would think that's okay
because it's within the context of a
choreographed dance it's not just
beyonce random it's not just out at the
gas station just
look like you just pulled some girls and
was like hey i'm sierra come twerk real
quick so it's not literally the video
she's just working on the car there's no
like this is a build up to an album drop
it's just nothing isn't it
nothing i think maybe it's a build up to
an album draw but it's made to look like
it's not giving a lot of benefits
it's amazing
was too much no no i'm just
i said i wouldn't i wouldn't i wouldn't
deal with it yeah but but she's here she
doesn't yeah i mean she doesn't care
about anyone
album draw does beyonce need to twerk to
build up for an album drop no
beyonce just like so why do you think
she did it what do you think
because women
women need attention
i think she i think she misses being in
the spotlight i think she misses being
the center of attention because she's
really attractive and so in her 20s like
she was she yeah she was the it girl and
so i think you know in her mid-30s it's
like time's running out and so that's
why i always see these girls doing these
like nude photo shoots like hillary
didn't hillary duff just do one too it's
like right at that party's about to end
and they're like real quick let me show
the world my body
let me
and
i could see i'm not saying she did it
because of that i can see sierra
doing it to be like yeah i still got it
that girl that was in the ride music
video yeah that's the same girl that's
doing it right now i still got the body
after three kids i still got it just
insecure you're saying
possibly
is that like
so why do you have to be insecure
like when you're doing these things why
does it have to be insecurity i honestly
don't think it's insecurity like because
i think oftentimes that's a cop-out
women use and say i'm just insecure and
like that that's why i'm doing it no
offense but like
but
i like to me i just think she wants
attention i think like girls like that
are used to having a ton of attention
but
how long has sierra been beautiful she
doesn't know what it's like to not be
beautiful yeah because she still is it's
for now it's not like a long time yet no
not really i mean guys at some point at
some i don't know we're not really
checking for sierra though
yeah well no yeah
there was a time where halle berry was
the most beautiful woman in the world
okay not saying that she's ugly now but
you don't hear people she was she was
irrelevant then she's not relevant
though yeah difference yeah so beautiful
not relevant it's just at some point
like men aren't lining up to date 50
year olds
so at some point the party ends it's
some some women are just hot enough they
make it to 40 and they're still hot yeah
but that's the exception it's not the
rule and sierra knows her party is
ending soon and life is going to be very
different because she doesn't know what
it's like to not be beautiful so she
wants to maintain it basically yeah i
just i think she's getting all the
attention she can because time's running
that's my my take is that she's getting
all the time she can because like
honestly girls that are born like nines
and tens part of me feels bad for them
because they don't they don't know what
it's like to not have that attention and
their whole life that's been who they
are
is stunning like they come into a room
they're used to everybody staring at
them and so when it runs out they don't
they don't have anything left
she's 36. that's why people idolize um
the girl that used to be ugly that
glowed up because
she she knew what it was like when she
was ugly for the door to hit you in the
face because men weren't holding the
door open struggle her personality is
good they actually come and shine free
[Music]
applaud for the throw the glow up
what did you say i said
the glow up girls
that's the thing they're always the
funniest too
you're in this shot have you been cute
you've always like
you were never ugly come on come on i
had my
face were you ever fat
no i've always been athletic built
but the face is the body can be one way
but the face could be another
menthol like 50 of women
so i'm gonna wear a bag on my face
you could why do you why do you think
guys would have do like sex dolls
yeah
they don't really yeah you guys wow
that's true and why do you think they
say butterface i don't care
like
it's dark anyways we ain't got to see
your face man that is true this is crazy
they sweat 50 of the time on dating apps
man
[Music]
yeah i believe that like some of my
friends have tinder plus and they're
just like
tender
man it's in the plus
okay i'm gonna read super chat um i saw
one from zantians i saw him roast me
oh no i know hold on okay um zasian 12.
i'm quite sure twerk sure twerking is
just a stripper move and a common one at
that so i'm wondering if strippers are
becoming more public than private
oh that's true
yeah
um 90 free topaz blue dress um forgive
your mom and return to your dad
because if you know what we're going
through
thanks you don't know he leaves this
comment a lot actually it's not just
this
like
i've like seen this comment copy paste
like you said that to me before
i'm like i'm i'm good i'm like i'm like
i like my pants
okay sentience blondie you're missing
the point like you're missing a